dolis shashin
he's allowed a run in all but one of his
six appearances this year in nearly six
era
jasin hasn't recorded a win in his last
17
starts oh and nine in that time jesse
winker number one in the national league
in batting average
advancing to home plate check swing on a
breaking ball
see you later jesse winker down to third
bruce dreckman said he went
strikeout for chasing to begin the night
nick castellanos
got a scheduled day off yesterday ground
ball left side diving stopped by fuentes
gets to his feet throws to joe
in time josh fuentes feeling it at the
plate
and usually when that happens the
defense comes right along with
it two outs nobody on for the
left-handed hitting center fielder tyler
naquin
he hits a ground ball up the middle in
the shift story's got it to the right of
second
throws out naquin pitch count well just
nine to get out of inning number one
for justine tyler o'malley he's had one
hiccup in a game where the ball was
flying for everybody
you're not going to have a perfect start
every single time i don't care what kind
of pitcher that you are
but for the most part here this year
saved that cub start his
outings have been awfully good rymel
tapia back in the lineup after
sitting out last night's game bounces
this one up the middle diving try goes
off the glove of farmer in the short
center field rymel thinking two
digs into second in with a head first
slide rymel
tapia with a hustle double the rockies
have scored in the first inning
in each of the first two games they want
to keep that going
connor joe will try and keep things
moving
high fly connor joe to right castellanos
indeed bright makes the catch easy tag
from second for tapia
one down and a man at third trevor story
the hitter
lead target swang of the miss big k for
tyler malley
gives hope for the reds of having their
first
scoreless opening inning of the series
but ryan mcmahon has other ideas
he's due for a homer his last home run
was april 27th in san francisco
it's well hit to right field this ball
game has another
first inning scoring first for the
rockies
touch of all time ending a long
dry spell with the long ball gets number
nine
and the rockies are up two to nothing so
rymel tapia
with a chance to expand the rockies
advantage
and the ground ball to first scooped up
by alex blandino he'll take it to the
bag for the out three unassisted
and the inning is over tyler o'malley
works around a little traffic on the
bases here in the second and mally
walks well that that is a bad decision
by
jolie and now you turn the order over
with a runner aboard and here's nick
castellanos
oh that pitch hangs and castellanos
kills it club to left field and
gone his team leading tenth home run
castellanos ties the game with a
two run over tyler kinley here in the
fifth call to the bull mckinley will
get the number eight hitter blandino
back to
better effort bouncing ball to third
fuentes has it sets his feet throws
across the diamond
and they take care of blandino for the
second time tonight on a groundout
malley swings at the first pitch pops it
up foul ground
first base side up against the screen
and
grabbed by connor joe big smile on his
face after
handling the play i think he learned
something there
get to the screen put your body against
it
give yourself a little more room and
grab the ball before it hits the screen
so a couple of quick outs for
kinley with the bottom of the order now
he faces the
lead off man jesse winker on one pitch
and there's a drive to wright going back
and near the track daza will snag it
and kinley posts a quick zero here in
the top of the fifth
halfway through tied at two third game
of this four
game series between the reds and rockies
colorado taking the first two
here's the pitch and reaching for it
tapia pops one into left
and jesse winker will move back a step
or two to make the catch for out number
one
now connor joe
grounded to suarez
two down as he works here to trevor
story with nobody on and two out in the
fifth and story swings the first pitch
pops it up that'll get it done
out goes jonathan indian shallow right
field the catch is made side retired
so here's the payoff pitch in jonathan
india that's a breaking ball misses
inside and he'll reach base with two
outs
so two out walk and we'll go to alex
blandino stevenson a long look here it
comes
oh and he hits blandino right
on the left arm ball four how about that
walk the bases loaded here by walking
the pitcher tyler malley
a four-pitch walk to put malley on a
career 100 hitter
with perhaps the best hitter in baseball
do up great opportunity now to break a
2-2 tie with the reds
with bases loaded two outs jesse winker
will come up to face the
new pitcher in the ball game justin
lawrence swung on and grounded to the
right side
charging mcmahon has it throws to first
and lawrence gets the job done as winker
flips the batting helmet away and now
o'malley to go to work against hampson
this ball was driven to center field and
deep
going back still going back he's going
to short off the wall
is triple territory garrett hanson will
get there easily
another triple for hampton his
third back to back with a triple and
what a time for it right over the head
of nate quinn
still at third with one out in the
seventh ballgame tied at two
and charlie blackman will pinch it fling
and a miss on a high fastball
and a three pitch strikeout and a key
one for
tyler malley now rymel tapia tapia one
for three a double
go ahead run at third base two outs
ground ball india and tyler malley
navigates through a quagmire a lead off
triple stranded 90 feet away
armor into third base and back to the
top of the order and another opportunity
for jesse winker here's the 3-2
miss he got him and the reds
strand two more here's garrett hampson
last rocky to reach he led off the
seventh inning with a
triple the hanson drives it deep center
field did he click
in akiyama the stabbing grab
and a warm embrace from winker antone
loves it
a stellar catch by shogo akiyama and
that
shepherds in more extra innings one down
man on second tie ball game now kyle
farmer the batter
and he rocks that one high in the air
deep left field
kyle farmer clobbers a go-ahead home run
and the reds take a 4-2 lead in the 11th
inning
tying runs on and the potential winning
run
josh fuentes comes to home plate driven
towards left center field it's going to
score
two is coming through yet again
nick castiano's will come up leading off
the reds 12th inning castiano sends it
to right
winker could jog hole castellanos a run
scoring double
pinch hit single for senzelle and
that'll bring a eugenio suarez to the
plate
and there's a bouncing ball to third off
the glove of fuentes they go across to
first a one hop throw
in time but castellanos will score
and it's now six five reds two outs
austin gomber is gonna pinch it first
ball swinging a little roller to the
right side that'll be gloved by blandino
in time the reds survive in a dozen